le comité prévention addiction existe
depuis une dizaine d'années au sein de
l'hôpital Charcot à plaisir et depuis
deux ans un accent est mis sur la
prévention du cannabis jusqu'alors les
réunions étaient internes mais pour la
première fois une session d'information
a été ouverte à tous les plus riches
disciplinaires que peuvent être les
professionnels soignants et les
professionnels scolaires elle s'est
tenue au Centre communautaire en tant
que infirmier déjà professionnel
travaillant sur un CMP on a repéré que
beaucoup d'adolescents ont des
problématiques de consommation de
cannabis et que beaucoup de
d'intervenants scolaires ou soignants se
retrouvent un petit peu seul dans les
prises en charge avec les adolescents
l'intérêt c'est avant tout de débattre
ensemble de la consommation du cannabis
et de la problématique du cannabis mais
aussi de créer des réseaux pour mieux
travailler ensemble chez les plus jeunes
il y a beaucoup plus de jeunes qui prend
du cannabis aujourd'hui qu'il y a 10 ou
15 ans et d'autre part les produits le
cannabis est beaucoup plus concentré
aujourd'hui donc beaucoup plus
à des effets beaucoup plus forts
aujourd'hui que qu'il y a 10 ou 15 ans
dans les centres d'addictologie une très
forte proportion de garçons 9 patients
sur 10 c'est une pathologie dont
l'origine se situe dans le développement
difficile qu'à le garçon de se dégager
de la relation qu'il a avec sa mère
intervenir donc avant la prise du
produit car les troubles psychiatriques
liés au cannabis sont réels c'est connus
comme un produit qui permet de
déclencher
l'ensemble des troubles psychiatriques y
compris les plus graves
les troubles anxieux ça c'est certain la
dépression c'est certain le trouble
bipolaire de l'humeur
et certainement très aggravée et puis
surtout ce qui est tout à fait alarmant
le cannabis peut précipiter du côté de
la schizophrénie des jeunes qui a priori
auraient pu échapper à ce destin là on
estime aujourd'hui que 6 adolescents sur
10 ont déjà fumé du cannabis